Hey guys, it's Jan here!
The latest movie I've caught on the big screen
is Disney's newest animated feature, Zootropolis,
which, depending what country you're in, is
also called Zootopia!
The film follows what happens when a scam-artist
fox and a hard-working rabbit who's a rookie
cop join together to crack a mysterious case
of missing mammals.
Basically, it's a mix of buddy cop movie,
odd-couple comedy, and classic whodunit with
shades of film noirs like Chinatown.
The voice cast is superb and features the
likes of Luther's Idris Elba as cape buffalo
cop Chief Bogo and Whiplash's JK Simmons as
Mayor Lionheart.
And I love the teaming up of Once Upon A Time
star Ginnifer Goodwin as the optimistic rabbit,
Judy Hopps, and Arrested Development's Jason
Bateman as the laid-back hustling fox, Nick
Wilde.
They play really nicely off each other and
make a superb comic duo.
Pop star Shakira also gets a cameo as a pop
star called Gazelle, and performs a new upbeat
and super-earwormy song called Try Everything,
written by Sia and Stargate.
Speaking of music, the film's score was composed
by Michael Giacchino, and as you'd expect
it perfectly fits the movie's tone throughout,
right down to its Hitchcock and The Godfather-inspired
moments.
In case you're interested, it's actually Giacchino's
first score for a feature-length animated
Disney movie, though, of course, he's done
plenty of brilliant work for Pixar including
Inside Out, The Incredibles, and Up.
Directors Byron Howard, who gave us Tangled,
Rich Moore, who gave us Wreck-It Ralph, and
Jared Bush, who's directing for the first
time and also co-wrote the script with Wreck-It
Ralph writer Phil Johnston, have done a great
job bringing to life the beautifully detailed
city of Zootropolis.
And Disney's animators deserve handfuls of
high fives all round for creating such a beautifully
colourful and incredibly well-thought-out
world which is cleverly divided into different
districts based on climates and species.
For example, there's Sahara Square for desert
animals, Tundratown for polar bears and moose,
and for rodents Little Rodentia, which is
the location of an ingenious chase scene.
The story itself feels particularly apt and
well-timed, dealing as it does with prejudice
and inclusivity, using different species and
specifically the idea of predators and prey
as an interesting way into those issues, playing
both with and against people's preconceived
notions of different animals, from shrews
to sloths, and elephants to cheetahs.
The film mainly manages to avoid being preachy
and only feels a touch on the nose at times.
The movie is full of knowing humour, including
jokes about Disney's own movies, and you'll
also see and hear tons of pop culture references
and some brilliantly funny easter eggs to
well-known films and TV shows.
In fact, I've made a video with all those
easter eggs and references, and I'll put the
link here as soon as it's live!
So, to sum up, Zootropolis is a charming odd-couple
comedy which blends a gorgeously realised
world, superb voice cast, timely message,
and elements from classic films and pop culture
to create a movie that has plenty to keep
both adults and kids entertained.
At around 1 hour 50 minutes, the movie feels
a touch on the long side, but I did still
very much enjoy my time visiting the city
of Zootropolis.
Zootropolis gets 4 out of 5 Flicks.
Now, tell me what you're looking forward to
about Zootropolis!
And if you've seen it already, what did you
think?
And who are your favourite Disney characters
and why?
Let me know in the comments below!
As well as my Zootropolis Easter Eggs video,
I'll also have a video up soon with fun facts
about Zootropolis.
I'll add annotations here once they're ready
to watch!
If you like this review, I really appreciate
you sharing it, and do feel free to subscribe
as I've got lots more videos on Disney, Pixar,
and other animated movies!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!